Which Burberry would you suggest for me to add to my protocol at midi a day is the
question which Burberry to add to the whole and how many a day see if I can get
to it a wake up to the street is so small all right so you guys can see that it's
really small but apologize the Burberry clear is our private labeled Burberry
to designs for health burberry to the reason why I like it is scat burberry and
ALA alphalopeic acid and that's what makes it so good for cancer patients. So
Burberry clear in at three per day and try to split it up as best you can I
know some people are like oh I'm not very good at split up by supplements will
then take two of the morning and one of the evening if you even split it up
morning lunchtime and dinner that would even be better and it was hard for
some people to do that it's hard for me to do that